the suspect is on the run tonight after
shooting seven people on u.s 95 the
highway was closed for hours from
horizon to boulder highway as
authorities continue to investigate now
good evening and thank you for joining
us tonight at 6 30. i'm sasha loftness
this all happened around 12 30 this
afternoon right now traffic is backed up
as many are heading back from lake mead
in willow beach madison kimbrough joins
us live near wagon wheel in the u.s 95
with the latest tonight madison
yeah traffic moving at a much better
pace as you can see there's really no
traffic as of now but the last couple
hours it has been bumper to bumper here
on wagon wheel and highway 95. according
to henderson police seven people were
injured with six people transported to
the hospital two of those six in
critical condition this after a shooting
took place on highway 95 and horizon
drive while driving southbound we saw
several police cars and motorcycles
stopped off the side of the road
henderson police say the suspect is
still on the run as of now horizon drive
from pacific to highway 95 has since
reopened but that was shut down in both
directions creating a traffic nightmare
those we spoke to say they just want to
get back home
it's terrible we all need to go to the
bathroom and we can't we can't because
we're all stuck here
and it's really worse like
if we only can walk and run to our place
then we should but we can't we're all
stuck here
again highway 95 northbound and
southbound moving at a good pace again
you can see cars are moving pretty
swiftly through that green light
currently awaiting more details from
henderson police on those involved in
the shooting as the suspect is still on
the run reporting live in henderson
madison kimbrough live local now